CNN forgets why their company is still
around okay I dare you to go watch CNN's
documentary how they made it go watch
the videos at the beginning when they
were first doing 24 7 dues and that
Turner came out go see what buildings
they worked in go see how many nights
Ted Turner slept in the office go he
eventually slept on the floor above
where everybody was working he just
slept in the building people were there
24 7 to make CNN work the CNN employees
of today should be so grateful for the
people at the beginning stages of CNN
that slept in the office that sacrificed
that gave their lives away so you can
now make 10 20 million and some of the
guys can make two three four hundred
thousand dollars as Executives and CNN
is what it is today at least what it
used to be a few years ago because right
now the ratings came out yesterday and
it's terrible I feel bad for CNN that
they're going through these challenging
times hopefully the new guy is going to
fire the right people and bring the
right people and change that